this is the opening scene from scream
and this is the opening scene from
scream two
they're supposed to look almost
identical they're both showing the
murder of the same character but when
you put them next to each other the
original stab looks way more realistic
because of the way they use this
horror movie props are carefully
designed to make you think they're real
thanks to a little movie magic
[Music]
this is nate reagan a scream aficionado
who worked on screen 4 and 5 and who has
a bunch of props from the movies
this is a hero knight from scream two
ghost face costume from scream three
hero knives for scream three this is an
actual buck knife for the original
scream they literally just took an
actual buck knife and they dulled it
down like they rounded off the tip and
they dulled it
centuries ago dull knives and swords and
daggers were used in stage duels and
that translated pretty seamlessly to
early adventure films and later to films
with violent killers
dull knives work really well on screen
for hero shots or close-ups that sell
that the knife is real
but a dulled knife is still incredibly
dangerous and safety is paramount on
film sets
there are tons of rules for using items
as innocuous as fog machines or makeup
all the way to the most dangerous
pyrotechnics to avoid accidents
filmmakers often use a variety of prop
knives for different shots then stitch
them together into one scene
the plastic ones were what they would
use if it was ever like pointed in
someone's face anywhere an actor's face
it would either be rubber or plastic
when the killer's like running he's
probably holding one of the rubber
knives just in case you know he falls on
it then of course you would have like
the retractable hitting the person
and then when they pull the retractable
out
that's another shot and then it would go
back to the real knife in the hand with
blood on it
in a video about the making of screams
one through three the founder of knb efx
group a special effects company had this
to say about his work you know this
wasn't a monster movie and it didn't
have a ton of effects in it you know we
had a few uh the old-fashioned gore gags
with the collapsible knives with
practical effects less is sometimes more
the reason this shot and scream 2 looks
fake is because they showcased the
wobble of an imperfect retractable stab
whereas in the original itali's the
glove is completely hiding that awkward
kind of wonky looking handle
the thing with the retractable knife is
it's easy for the blade to bind up and
if the blade binds up then all of a
sudden you're stabbing them for real
there's horror stories of some there was
a theater and then they had retractable
knives when he got hit just below the
pad so it actually punctured his lung
while he was out on stage eric hart is a
prop maker and stage props professor at
north carolina university there's a lot
of things we do we can do pyrotechnics
we can hang actors we can do all sorts
of stuff and we can make it safe but you
can't
make a retractable knife sick
to avoid these risks filmmakers might
use digital replacements
in this vfx breakdown from zombieland 2
emma stone is holding just the hilt of a
knife the blade and the blood were both
added in post
but cg blood isn't always going to serve
the purpose sometimes you need the real
fake thing
[Music]
with a blood knife you usually have a
little container of blood
if you can you can hide it inside the
handle and then you just have some kind
of tube running down the blade
and you put that on the side that the
audience doesn't see it kind of tape it
in place
and then as soon as you drag the knife
across whatever you're cutting you kind
of squeeze the tube and time it so that
the blood starts coming out and then it
looks like the the knife is actually
cutting into the skin it's a simple
solution but in order for it to look
real it all depends on the blood
in the black and white era of hollywood
hershey's chocolate syrup was a frequent
blood standing most famously used in
alfred hitchcock's psycho the effect is
convincing but color film needed better
fake blood
in early films blood often looked too
thin or too bright like this scene from
the 1958 version of dracula you know
when you look at blood it's not pure red
you need a little bit of something else
in it by the 70s and 80s films like evil
dead and carrie were using a type of
blood called kensington gore
it was made by a british pharmacist and
named after a street of the same name in
london
the recipe included water food coloring
and the game changing factor corn syrup
which added thickness when it's dripping
off of you when it's flowing it's
flowing the way blood does it's not
dripping like red water
dick smith one of the godfathers of film
makeup took this recipe one step further
he added kodak photoflow a poisonous
wetting agent commonly used when
developing photo negatives this allowed
the blood to believably soak into
clothing while retaining that thickness
for this scene in scream you can see the
special effects team coding drew
barrymore's neck and clothes with fake
blood out of a ketchup squeeze bottle
movies today use a variation on all
these recipes depending on what the
scene calls for if it's coming out of a
blood knife it's got a flow you can't
have like really chunky stuff and if
they're actually swallowing it you want
it to be food safe if it's like
splattering on
carpets and you want to be able to wash
it out the next time you're watching
like a low budget heart check how many
times they have a really bloody scene in
the bathroom like in the shower because
that's really easy for them to clean
after they're done filming but in
situations where the blood has to be
more explosive filmmakers turn to
another prop
[Music]
squibs are tiny explosives often used
for gunshot scenes
before squibs filmmakers relied on
acting to sell bullet hits
this climactic death from the film high
noon is a good example of how that
doesn't always look right
[Music]
here roger george special effects is
demonstrating how their hit kit squibs
work
prop masters attach a small explosive to
a container filled with fake blood then
attach it to the actor usually with
something protective underneath a
licensed pyrotechnician will detonate it
at the right time and the blood will
seem to explode out of you
for larger blood spurts like these
ridiculous explosions at the end of the
campy movie ready or not filmmakers turn
to something else and that i do have i
got one of the blood cannons i built
it's the same as a confetti cannon but
with blood
for the bigger squirts like this one in
the babysitter films will often use air
pressure to spray blood continuously if
it's
hitting an artery then it would be like
pulsating out so you have somebody like
just off camera who's able to sort of uh
work the pump and the pressure with air
if you just need a slowly appearing pool
of blood underneath the body you could
just have like one psi of pressure just
slowly pushing that blood out
prop knives and blood are only one part
of making movies look real the rest of
the work is often hidden
after all it's what you don't see that
makes the difference
ghostface's most brutal attacks are
often slightly behind objects covered by
hands or just out of frame
the killer in psycho almost never
touches marion crane's actual body
and michael myers kills people off
screen
but the blood guts and sound effects
pull the trick on us making us feel like
we've seen it
[Music]
thanks so much for watching
we set out a few weeks ago to make a
video about how horror movies make fake
violence look real and while i was
editing this piece the importance of
prop safety was highlighted by some
really devastating news the tragic death
of dp helena hutchins on the side of the
film rust
when watching movies it can be really
easy to forget how high the stakes are
for the people involved while prop
accidents are uncommon they do happen a
similar incident happened in 1993 on the
side of the film the crow we don't talk
about firearm props in the piece but the
la times has a really thorough explainer
on how prop guns work which provides
some clarity about how a blank cartridge
might have ended up propelling
projectiles on the side of the crow the
topic can get really deep so if you're
interested in reading more we'll leave
some links in the description below